So here we have numpy imported which means we can
use.
We can work with.
A vectors and multi-dimensional arrays. So right now we're looking
we will look at the NP dot array. There's something called NP in
the array.
The numpy libraries quite comprehensive.
So we're going to go through
it go through its different features.
You know.
and in each session
So here it says number one create three vectors.
over RN
where n is equal to 5.
so 5 dimensional vectors
And declare these with v sub 1 V sub two V sub 3.
So what would V sub 1 look like it would have V sub 1?
And this would be equal to I'm just going to put any five networks.
I'm going to go one two.
three four five
okay, so this
These are all real numbers. Remember
the set of natural numbers are subset
of the set of real numbers.
So these are all.
Well, that's that's an example of one vector.
over RN
and then V2 could be.
Seven eight nine.
10 7 8 9 10 there's going
up any ground increments of one no particular reason for me to use
these numbers just
Any random number will do.
And then we have V3.
so 12 13
15 16
There we go.
So that's how we create.
three
vectors
that's for number two put the vectors inside the Matrix m.
That is a three by three by five Matrix. How do we create a
matrix that history file three by five?
So well if you want to create a matrix.
That's again just a multi-dimensionalistant python.
So what I'm just going to do is I'm going to remember a matrix is
a
is a is rows of vectors A Matrix
is a rows of vectors. That's one way to look at
it either Columns of rows.
Columns of vectors or rows of vectors here
we have
we'll go with rows. So this is row number one.
Which is a vector?
so these are all subsets of
the row space event
Okay, so V2.
And then V 3.
And now we have ourselves a matrix if I now
type in m.
There you can see.
if you use a math lab this
I mean the the coding approach would be very familiar.
Oh, by the way, if you want to work with math lab discourse will help you out.
A great deal. Maybe I can I'll add I'll add Snippets.
For master so we won't cover Matlab in the course,
but I'll give you the Matlab implementation of the Python code
that we're doing.
Matter, of course stands for Matrix laboratory if
I remember correctly.
Anyway, so now we have a matrix which
is a set of three subsets of three elements
where each element is itself a vector.
So that's element one element Two element three, how
do we turn this thing into an array
we go NP dot array.
And then you plug in your list.
I'm gonna go ahead and put
m in there
Now, of course I could have made these numpy erased first and then put them in
but the order doesn't matter not Pi will take care of it.
So let me add some comments in here. We will declare.
three vectors
over r
and then declare the Matrix
m
which is
2 by 3
and then here I'm just previewing The Matrix preview The
Matrix.
Okay.
Oh, excuse me, three by five.
Yes, three by five.
Okay. Yeah three rows.
of elements for each element is a
space of five components or five
elements
and then here we are going to convert The Matrix.
M.
M two
a numpy
multi-dimensional
well, that's actually not multi. It's actually affect It's actually an
array with three elements. So
an Empire rate
now, how do we get the
first element of the row space of them
if I want the first row.
I'm just going to go.
M 0 it's going to give you the first Vector inside the
Matrix.
M.
Okay, and then exactly I can
use I can use square bracket notation. If I want to add these three vectors together
for four number step number four. So add
the elements of the row space. What are the elements of the
of the row space?
They are M sub m zero, M1 and
M2.
And here's the thing in programming we start our
subscripts from 0 so we come from 0.
So this will be the first Vector second Vector third vector.
and then if you want to add them together, well, we just do just
The numpy allows you to add them together like so.
And we can call this the what should
we call this?
This will be V sub 4 remember what we said about the
vector space we said.
It is addition.
The closure Axiom applies to it under addition. So if
you add the if you add two vectors
together, you get a third Vector. That's what closures and you
will see now if I add these together.
And I say V sub 4.
There is my mistake. I did convert.
I did convert M to a numpy array, but
I did not reassign it so I'm gonna reassign it. Okay, so m is
gonna go from being a python listen to now being a
numpy array. Okay. I was missing this bit. So one
more time.
Now I'm going to create a fourth Vector out of the sum of
these pictures. And if I now say V4 there you
can see we've done.
vector addition
and that's the answer.